Let's take a look inside the home of one of the many tech entrepreneurial giants...
...living in the Mission District.
Come on up!
You're younger than I thought you'd be.
What's your name?
Max.
Max?
I bought the place in 2011 when the market was down.
You must've been two or three when you made that deal.
You have a lot of really nice stuff here.
What's your favorite piece in the house?
There.
Over there?
My friend made it,...
...he's six.
So, you have two guest bedrooms here?
For sleepovers!
This is your bedroom?
Yeah.
Wow!
This is like the size of my apartment.
This is where I like to meditate.
Excuse me for a second.
How are you so driven?
What?
I said, how are you so driven?
I just want to make the world a better place.